[lively music]
This is an exhibit
celebrating the 400th
anniversary of the First Folio,
which is the first edition of
the collected plays of
Shakespeare, published in 1623.
One reason why we
care about this book
and celebrate its anniversary
is that it preserves
about half of Shakespeare's
plays that otherwise might
have been lost, because they
don't appear in other
print editions from the period,
so plays like Macbeth
and The Tempest that we think of
as being absolutely essential
to the Shakespeare canon.
But I think another reason
why we celebrate this book is a
a bit more complicated and
connected to
Shakespeare's cultural
status, because the book
itself is not actually that rare
for an early modern book.
There's over 200 copies of it,
so its value seems less
connected to its rarity
or scarcity and more
connected to
the values and meanings
that we have brought to it
over the centuries.
I would be very happy
if people came to the
exhibit who didn't know
what the First Folio was.
To me, the really fascinating
story is how it became
so important, and in
the exhibit,
I was interested
in exploring that
intersection of turning
Shakespeare into a
commodity that could be
worth quite a lot.